the Marvel Cinematic Universe is an
immensely complex shared universe full
of stories but it's even a middle that
complexity the story of Steve Rogers aka
Captain America is particularly twisty
luckily for you we're here to make sense
of it all
this is Captain America's whole time II
why me MCU story explain Steve Rogers
was born in New York City in 1918 by the
time he reached adulthood he was an
orphan and relied instead on his chosen
family his best friend James Buchanan
Bucky Barnes by 1943 at World War two
raised in Europe both Steve and Bucky
were trying to enlist in the US Army
while Bucky was accepted Steve's
multiple chronic illnesses and small
stature led to constant rejection even
when he attempted to use fake names and
addresses to enlist steve's luck changed
when he met dr. Abraham Erskine the head
scientist in an experimental program
called project rebirth which aimed to
create a super soldier to help turn the
tide of the war for the Allies Steve was
accepted into the program on a trial
basis and his courage impressed one of
the programmers supervisors a British
officer and a strategic scientific
reserve named Peggy Carter others in the
program remained unconvinced that Rogers
was a man for the job
then came the moment that put Rogers
over the top in an effort to prove that
one of the strongest soldiers will be
better suited to the procedure SSR
Colonel Phillips threw a dummy grenade
on the ground at Camp
and that settled the matter Steve Rogers
would be the man to take her sky and
Super Soldier Serum Steve Rogers was
driven back to New York City to take
part in the project rebirth procedure
under skin supervision the night before
us go and warn them of previous attempts
that hadn't gone well including one on a
German officer named Johann Schmidt who
was at that very moment pursuing his own
ambitions in Europe as the leader of the
fascist organization known as Hydra
they were extremely painful Rogers
version of the procedure went smoothly
he emerged with a dramatic increase in
heights and muscle mass boasting
enhanced abilities and free of his
previous chronic illnesses Rogers first
encounter with Hydra sadly arrived just
moments after the procedure as a
hydrogen snuck into the room and gunned
down as gone Steve was able to pursue in
cash the agent but he took his own life
before it could be questioned as kinds
death changed the course of the SSR and
project rebirth as his formula
apparently died with him with only one
super soldier at their disposal the US
government pressed Steve Rogers into
service immediately but it wasn't the
kind of service he wanted Captain
America was viewed by Congress as more
important to the war effort
as a symbol than he was as a soldier so
Steve Rogers was dressed in a colorful
costume and sent on a tour throughout
the United States to sell war bonds
followed by a tour of Europe to increase
morale for the troops series II Defense
bonds each one you buy is a bullet in
the barrel of your best guys gun after
spending the rest of 1943 doing shows
instead of fighting battles Steve grew
weary and then saw his chance to fight
in Italy he learned that Bucky's unit
was m.i.a and opted to say to one man
rescue mission for his friend with the
help of Carter and industrialists Howe
was stuck he dropped behind enemy lines
and rescued Bucky and a number of other
troops proving himself as a frontline
asset in the fight against Hydra he also
met Schmitz
who revealed his own encounter with the
super soldier process had transformed
him into the Red Skull
in an effort to clear out Hydra and
disrupt US operations Steve recruited a
crack team of commandos
including Barnes and dum-dum Dugan and
they began a series of missions around
1944 to infiltrate Hydra bases and
rescue captured Allied soldiers
The Legend of Captain America grew by
1945 Captain America and his Howling
Commandos had succeeded in helping turn
the tide of the war but it came at great
cost during a mission to capture the red
scales chief aid Arnim Zola Bucky fell
to his apparent death leaving Steve and
the rest of the commandos to gain a
location of hydras final stronghold from
Zola Steve then discovered red skulls
endgame using a powerful artifact called
the tesseract later revealed as the
Infinity stone Schmitz engineered
weapons of mass destruction which he
planned to drop on America with the help
of a long-distance bomber Steve snuck on
board the plane and in the ensuing
confrontation Red Skull seemingly died
when the unshielded tesseract pulled him
through a wormhole
the tesseract then fell into the ocean
too late to be recovered by Howard Stark
with Hydra defeated Steve was left alone
on a damaged plane and realized he
couldn't risk landing it because there
was a chance of weapons would detonate
and kill countless civilians while
radioing with Peggy who had recently
shared his first kiss with Steve
revealed his intention to crash the
plane into the ocean and sacrifice
himself
Maggie
you're gonna need a rain check on that
dance so near the end of World War two
Steve Rogers flew a plane into the
Arctic Ocean and passed into legend
becoming an American hero who as far as
the rest of the world knew gave His life
to save countless others in the years
following his apparent death Captain
America became a national symbol of
heroism spawning everything from trading
cars to museum exhibits Peggy Carter
went on to co-found shield and later
married and started a family with Steve
always alive in her memory and it was
shield which continued to hold out hope
to at least discover his body at last in
the early 2010's
a breakthrough happened shield
scientists searching in the Arctic
uncovered the aircraft and Rogers intact
frozen body then discovered to their
amazement that Steve was somehow still
alive having been frozen in time by the
ice at first shield director Nick Fury
tried to keep Steve unaware that had
been in stasis for nearly seven decades
constructing a 1940s era hospital room
and even playing 1940's baseball games
on the radio until one day he heard a
game on the radio that he knew had
already been played his deception
revealed Fury appeared to Steve and
revealed the truth it was 2011 and he
would have to adjust to life in a new
world because he might need to save it
again someday
very soon in 2012 Rogers was called back
into action when the tesseract which
have been in shield custody for years
fell into the hands of Thor's brother
Loki who planned to use it to open a
wormhole and summon an alien army to
earth at furious urging and working
alongside SHIELD agent and Captain
America superfan Phil Coulson Steve
teamed up with Iron Man aka Tony Stark
Bruce Banner and his alter-ego the Hulk
and Thor rounding out the team was
shield operatives Black Widow and
Hawkeye aka Natasha Romanoff and Clint
bathroom respectively the group was
dubbed The Avengers the team's
relationship was rocky at first amid a
clash of personalities but Coulson's
death of Loki's hand galvanized them and
Steve in particular took point as a
field captain for the group when Loki
you stark tower to open his wormhole
over New York City the Avengers took to
the streets to fight the ensuing alien
Chitauri invasion with Steve often
taking point in getting civilians away
from danger in the chaos the wealth
security council opted to bomb New York
rather than rest the
vation spreading buttstock was able to
divert the missile while Romanov closed
the wormhole
after Sark narrowly escaped death the
Avengers took Loki and the tesseract
into custody sending both back to Asgard
with Thor their mission completes the
Avengers when their separate ways and
Steve became a full-time shield field
operative working closely with both fury
and Romanov steve remained an active
shield operative for the next two years
throwing himself into his work even as
he tried to learn as much as he could
about this new era everything changed
when after growing suspicious about data
are covered by Romanoff on a mission
fury was nearly killed by an assassin
known as the Winter Soldier working
while on the run from an internal
factions seeking to destroy them
Rogers and ramanathan covered the truth
Hydra had managed to infiltrate shield
and have been working as a sleeper cell
for years the new Hydra grew a beautiful
parasite inside fury was attacked
because he and Romanoff had found data
that could compromise hydras plan to use
shield assets to kill millions then
there was the biggest secret Bucky had
been kept in stasis for decades
brainwashed and given his own super
soldier treatments making him the Winter
Soldier
lucky lucky in the ensuing battle Steve
Romanov fury and Falcon aka Sam Wilson
were able to expose Hydra and stop its
planned attack at the last moment
Bucky escaped in the chaos after Steve
refused to kill him but not before
sparing and then saving Steve's life and
gaining a new curiosity about who he
really was with shield in ruins
following the Hydra discovery Rogers
reteamed for the Avengers to take out
the remaining Hydra cells now under the
command of Baron Wolfgang von Strucker
while infiltrating the last Hydra
stronghold in Europe the team discovered
two new metahumans Pietro and Wanda
Maximoff that gained their abilities
through strucker's experiments after
defeating Strucker
The Avengers faced a new threat when
Starks experimental AI technology known
as Ultron gained sentience and began
formulating a plan to wipe out humanity
to make a long story short
Ultron crippled the Avengers by having
Wanda use her mind-bending powers to
distract hypnotize and otherwise
splinter the team as a result a rift
formed between stark and Rogers as Steve
questioned Tony's motives in trying to
build what Tony called a suit of armor
around the world every time someone
tries to win a war before it starts
innocent people die every time the
Avengers regrouped in sokovia we're all
trying to attempted to launch an entire
city into the sky before dropping it
back to earth like an asteroid with the
help of the Maximus and Ultron's own
Android creation vision and with Rogers
again acting as field commander the team
was able to defeat Ultron's robotic army
and prevent the city from impacting
earth losing Pietro who gave His life to
say Clint in the process with Ultron
defeated the original Avengers went
their separate ways
so much so that Hulk fled the planet in
a Quinjet Rogers took command that the
team's new upstate New York facility and
prepared to train a new team of Avengers
with Romanov including Wanda Sam James
Rhodey Rhodes better known as war
machine and vision in 2016 Steve met two
new challengers the first came after an
operation by his New Avengers team
called civilian casualties leading a
number of nations to come together and
establish a sokovia accords a new system
of regulations that keep super-powered
heroes in check Stark believed in the
Accords were a necessary way to save
innocent
lives stood by the new policy while
Rogers stood in opposition believing
that to save his hands are still our own
the conflict was complicated by the
re-emergence of Bucky Barnes who could
still be triggered by various
brainwashing code words these code words
fell into the hands of Helmut Zemo who
launched a plan to bring down the
Avengers from the inside using Barnes
assassination of Howard Maria Stark in
1991 as a fulcrum points to make matters
even worse for good ol cap Peggy Carter
whom Steve had visited on her deathbed
around the same time that he was
reunited with Bucky passed away dealing
another emotionally draining blow to the
typically stoic hero rising tensions
finally culminated in a physical battle
between Stark and his loyal Avengers and
Rogers and his own squad the battle
continued at a secret Hydra facility in
Siberia where Stark learned that Barnes
had killed his parents Bucky and Steve
for Tony in a vicious battle before
escaping permanently fracturing the
Avengers Steve took Bucky to a condo in
an effort to finally remove his Winter
Soldier conditioning and began
performing covert operations with
Natasha Wanda and Sam as a fugitive from
the US government in an act of
friendship
Steve's left behind the letter and a
cellphone so Tony could call him at the
need ever arose more than a year Pastor
Steven esteem continued to carry out
covert operations around the world but
their time in hiding was interrupted
they had to rescue unlikely lovebirds
Wonder and vision from a pair of alien
invaders in Scotland this was followed
by a call from a returned Bruce Banner
who revealed to Steve that Thanos had
begun his final push for the Infinity
stones threatening all life in the
universe vision who held the mine stone
in his head offered his life if it meant
the stone would be destroyed and fellows
would be stopped but Steve refused
while Tony carried out his own fight
with Fano soft planets Steve called in a
favor to King to charla of Wakanda and
the two prepared for a pitched battle in
a secluded African nation Thanos his
army arrived in a push to get the mine
stone and Steve led the charge to hold
him off for wakandan scientists Cherie
tried to remove the stone from vision so
it could be destroyed though Thor Groot
and Rocket arrived to reinforce their
fight
that'ss himself later appeared to take
the stone monday used her power to
destroy us but Thanos use the time stone
to rewind time and take the mine stone
from visions head though Thor nearly
killed
Thanos Thanos snapped his fingers
wielding all six Infinity stones wiping
out half of all life in the universe
three weeks after the battle in Wakanda
Stephen a team of Avengers were shocked
by the return of Tony Stark and the
appearance of Carol Danvers Captain
Marvel together they learn that Thanos
had used the stones again on a distant
planet and Steve led a team to go there
and take the stones back when they
arrived they found that Thanos had used
the stones to destroy the stones
rendering their efforts useless Thor /
headed fellows in a rage and the team
returned home five years passed during
which time Steve did his best to be a
help to others and a well decimated by
Thanos you did the hardest part the jump
you didn't know where you're gonna come
down and that's it that's those little
brave baby steps we got to take more
Natasha led field operations for the
remaining Avengers Steve spent much of
his time in New York City
attending support groups for survivors
and trying to keep morale up while
acknowledging that he himself was having
trouble moving on from defeat everything
changed when Scott Lang ant-man
re-emerged after being lost in the
quantum realm and revealed to Steven
Natasha that time travel could be a
possible solution - in doing venosus
harm they approached Stark who was at
first reluctant to help births after
cracking the time-travel problem
returned to the Avengers facility to
launch a mission to retrieve the stones
using Pym particles as their time-travel
fuel the Avenger split into teams to
journey back to previous encounters with
the Infinity stones in order to steal
them and form a gauntlet of their own
that wouldn't do that noise - snap
Steve journeyed with stark Banner and
Lang to New York in 2012 and
successfully recovered the mine stone
after a battle with his own past self
since the space stone was lost after it
fell into loki's hands Tony and Steve
needed to launch an unplanned journey to
1970 New Jersey to recover it at a
secret shield facility well there Steve
stole Pym particles to facilitate the
trip home though Natasha was lost during
her mission to capture the mine stone
the Avenger succeeded in getting all six
Infinity stones and banner now a source
of Bruce Hulk hybrid snapped to undo the
decimation it works but moments later a
past version of Thanos arrived having
learned of the Avengers plan via
nebulous memory banks a battle ensued in
upstate New York and at one point Steve
was the last soldier standing
he proved himself worthy of wielding
Leonia and led the reformed Avengers and
a massive fight which culminated in Tony
sacrificing himself by welding the
stones and using them to kill Thanos and
his entire army and then the infinity
war once and for all with Thanos
defeated it was important that the
Avengers returned the Infinity stones to
the exact places where they took them to
prevent disastrous alternate timelines
from continuing and disrupting the flow
of time in general Steve took this
responsibility on himself and thought a
conversation with Bucky about his plans
before leaving after Tony's funeral
Steve stepped back on the time platform
and returned the stones to their
previous locations Steve was only
supposed to be gone for a matter of
seconds for the Avengers in 2023 but he
missed his time stamp where is he Steve
had saved extra Pym particles to use
after returning the stones and use them
to travel back to the 1940s to reunite
with Peggy Carter and live out the rest
of his life in peace with her he didn't
reveal himself to the Avengers again
until moments after he left them in 2023
appearing on a bench by the lake of the
Avengers upstate facility to reveal what
he had done now an old man had spent the
last half of his life happily married he
handed over his shield to Sam Wilson
making him the next Captain America
while also declining to reveal any
details about his married life you want
to tell me about her no no the only
glimpse await the audience gets of
Steve's second chance at a normal life
is a dancer Steve had promised Peggy all
those years ago check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the MCU are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]